where is he she's in the car where you
left her
a Georgia man is now in police custody
after he allegedly kidnapped his
ex-girlfriend from her job LED police on
a high-speed chase then shot and killed
her after crashing his vehicle over to
the car put her in the car she
approached you know she was protesting
it happened on July 16th in Fayetteville
Georgia about 30 minutes south of
Atlanta at about 11 o'clock that evening
dispatched there received a call for a
kidnapping in progress investigators say
the suspect 20-year-old Cameron Hopkins
forced his ex-girlfriend 19-year-old
Kalia Jones to leave work at a Wingstop
restaurant and get into his car
Witnesses told First Responders Hopkins
had a gun
[Music]
after we were
looking at what he did is
he had the lady that waited upon us and
was escorted out of here by him
said something that was inaudible to me
and she continued to do what she was
supposed to be doing I guess waiting on
everybody and finally he appeared to be
a little frustrated so what he did is he
walked behind the counter the lady I'm
assuming that was the manager what are
you doing don't be going Beyond this
point
he proceeded to go in the back
accosted her back toward the rear of the
store grabbed her by the arm and walked
around here with a weapon
okay when you walked out of the store
what did he did you see anything outside
the store
say it again officer did you see when
they left the store did you see what
type of vehicle they got in anything
like that he had to be something on the
border of a Camaro type of vehicle red
in color okay
where were they parked at over there on
the other side of that white car over by
that building there okay a vehicle was
facing
um that way
he backed out drove down a little bit
into the parking lot then turned around
and went out of the parking lot okay
would you be willing to write a
statement I want you to put this if you
want me to man yeah let's do my stuff
going on I know it's a lot going on but
if you don't mind the juicy and yeah I
was on the side
um I I didn't see him walk around like
my dad did
when I heard the commotion the manager
saying you can't come behind here what
are you doing yeah be accosted the young
lady later on he had uh he's gone on
them what color was you know what type
of farm was it uh it was tan tan tan
handle uh I'm going to assume it's
probably a nine millimeter okay wow okay
um he took her out
went over took her over there because we
at that point my dad was out I was
worried about him so I you know I rushed
outside and I watched him he marched her
right over to the car put her in the car
she approached you know she was
protesting but you know he had a weapon
so he wasn't alive she was going to do
and uh took her in the car like he said
he drove over there did a semi-circle
and he went down that way
she was already in the process of
believe calling before this incident
Hopkins was already charged for
kidnapping Jones once before he was
released on bond in that case in
September of last year body camera video
shows Fayetteville Police Officers
following Hopkins on a chase through
both Fayette and Clayton counties
[Music]
12 months clear the pit
all right we're coming up on the curry
Park speeds
it's gone to 95.
over 100 about 105.
take down the road coming up on Focus
Road
blacking out
[Music]
I'll pick the one I'm trying to get to
them
okay well we're still on McDonald Road
speeds at about 90 coming up to Chelsea
Drive ready a new contracted a great
Italian hours
dash camera video shows officers catch
up with Hopkins and eventually Ram into
his vehicle it comes to a stop near
Lovejoy High School in nearby Hampton
Georgia
I'm gonna take the one I'm trying to get
y'all
okay well we're still on McDonald Road
speeds at about 90. coming up to Chelsea
Drive ready as you contacted a great
town yard
[Music]
he just hit a meeting he's probably
gonna go flat here shortly
21 15 to 55 to answer your phone
it looks like they turned into the high
school here at the middle school
okay
[Music]
as officers get out of their squad cars
shots are fired
[Music]
radio shots fired shots fired
I am behind you I'm behind you
I don't know
look right here they're still in the
vehicle with shots being fired
you and it's a bus Clayton
units advise we're at Lovejoy High
School if we can get some music coming
to the back side of the school
knock them off
there's two occupants
two occupants in the car
after this officers call for Hopkins to
get out of the vehicle
you got rifle all right
hey give him a vehicle based on yeah
yeah they're both still in the car
coming to y'all
two we hear female talking right now
um
no no no they started popping as I was
in my driver's seat and got out
okay let's just make sure we stay on the
hill
I was trying to see if we can definitely
who's that hold on
we got somebody coming in the back side
of this High School
Ace Clayton who was that
all right
I'm good bro hey
he's coming out no I got this
he's coming up down him right there by
the car
the passenger door
climb out yeah
make him time out
hold on hold on hold on
I'm coming with the shield
back up there ain't no point moving up
on him call his ass come out come out
the car passenger looks to see come out
climb over
come out come out of the window
get out
come out of the window come out the
window come out of the window
she's deceived she's going online
man get out of the fucking car man
get out of the get out of the car
crawl out
you want to move up on them crawl out
negative no negative
hey we will but we need you out of the
car
get out of the car man get out of the
get out come out just come out of the
car for us
son you gotta come out of the car man
crawl out
no no no no no
one voice
you give voices
come out come on man look come out of
the car and we can help you and we can
help her keep your hands where I can see
you
keep your hands open
come out
look man come out in the car so we can
cut down to her
come out get out of the car so we can
help her
step out there you go step out step on
the ground on the ground on the ground
on the ground
get on the ground
[Applause]
on the ground get out of the car so we
can help her
foreign
step out there you go step out step on
the ground on the ground on the ground
no get on the ground
get on the ground
on the ground
crawl to us crawl to us crawl to us hey
you take more hands warning somebody
still covering the car come to us
they crawl to us right now you ready
one voice
warning you got hands and commands come
to us do it now
more
according to a release from the
Fayetteville Police Department officers
used a less lethal method to lure
Hopkins out of his vehicle they call it
a quote OC type irritant that affected
his eyes once he's out of the crashed
vehicle body camera video shows officers
pour water over hopkins's eyes where
they had become irritated Hopkins
appears to be crying asking where Jones
is
stick your head out we're gonna dump
this on you so you can get some of that
OC out of your eye
turn this turn your head the other way
you want some more
you want more
yes or no do you want more water can I
use remote
where is she she's in the car where you
left her
officers can be heard discussing what
happened saying they believe Hopkins
shot and kill Jones
let me come around this way and yeah
then I couldn't see inside the car I
knew she was in there so I was like
locking a fire and hit her but I saw two
people now I thought I actually had a
black hood because I it it passed me
Southbound on 314 after I just left a
pair of Kenwood I was like I can't be
going Southbound on 314 from the
Wingstop
and it turned left onto Banks and I went
down 85 to turn around
and see if it was it and I just lit it
up and he took off
hey he he popped him around some rounds
off into my windshield as I was bailing
out
I'm fairly certain he shot her I mean
she got a shot to her head she's 109 D
she's the best time
Hopkins now faces charges of kidnapping
and aggravated assaults out of Fayette
County he faces multiple charges out of
Clayton County as well including murder
and possession of a weapon he's due back
in court on August 7th reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie